I was seeing six blue whales
in an area the size
of a soccer pitch.
I've gone on to name them
the "unorthodox whales,"
because they actually break
the stereotypes
we had for this species.
it has sent me on an
incredible adventure.
(audience clapping)
It was back in 2003.
I was working on a
whale research vessel
that was circumnavigating
the globe.
On this particular
day of significance,
I was standing up on
deck, straining my eyes,
looking out for this
pod of sperm whales
that we'd tracked
all night long.
I could hear their
sounds eminating from
the pilot house below me,
but I just couldn't see them.
I knew what I was
looking for, this short
lofty blow slanted off
to the left hand side,
super characteristic
of sperm whale.
I searched and I
looked for hours
on end and I couldn't find them.
But then I saw this,
a tall, powerful,
vertical blow that
rose all the way
to the sky as far
as I could tell.
This animal was at
least two kilometers
away from us, but it
was an incredible sight,
and I knew it could
only come from
an animal that was incredibly
large and powerful.
So I got super excited,
as you would as well,
and I grabbed my walkie-talkie
and I called down to my captain.
I said, "Bob, Bob, 11 o'clock,
two kilometers, go go
go," and he says, "Why?"
And I said, "I think
it's a blue whale,"
and he says, "Sure."
Get's off course, starts
cruising the direction
that I've now sent him
off in, and I am now,
like so afraid and paranoid
to lose this visual.
My eyes are streaming as
I stare into the glare.
I'm trying so hard
to just focus,
and that's when I think I've
started to lose my mind.
(audience laughing)
Because it wasn't just one
blue whale I was seeing.
I was seeing six blue whales in
an area the size
of a soccer pitch.
I'm thinking to myself, why
on earth would an animal,
the largest that has
ever roamed the planet,
with the freedom to
travel 70% of our planet,
choose to just aggregate in this
tiny little spot in a
warm tropical ocean?
So, I was fresh out of
undergrad, and I started
to think about what
I'd been taught.
Thought about my
textbooks and what
my professors had
said, and I remembered,
large whales like
blue whales undertake
long-range migrations
between cold feeding areas
and warm breeding
and calving areas.
That was it.
I was super stoked.
(audience laughing)
I was going to be the
first person on the planet
to document blue
whales having sex.
(audience laughing)
So I, you know, I
thought, this is awesome,
my career is made,
fame and fortune.
What do people complain
about, this is so easy, gosh.
(audience laughing)
So I'm there egging
the captain on.
I'm like, "Bob, we have to go.
"This is going to
be incredible!"
So, we're moving
forward, getting there,
we're moving as fast as
this boat can take us,
and we get there, and it is
not what you think it is.
There's not a single
whale penis in sight.
(audience laughing)
I am super disappointed,
because these whales
are now lolling at the
surface, hanging out,
occasionally one will
dive, come back up,
and I'm like, what
the heck is going on?
My dreams that I
had created for the
last two kilometers of my life
were completely shattered.
(audience laughing)
And I was like, oh my god, what
am I going to do with my life?
But I insisted that
we stayed around
and watched for
a little, 'cause,
you know, this was my
first blue whale, or six.
And that's when I saw this.
This, ladies and gentlemen,
is a pile of blue whale poop.
(audience laughing)
What's most exciting about this
is not just the
stunning red color,
but the fact that there
was poo, which meant
these animals were
feeding somewhere close.
Now remember what I
told you at the start.
Blue whales undertake long range
migrations between
cold feeding areas
and warm breeding
and calving areas.
Sri Lanka is five degrees
above the equator,
as warm and as
tropical as it can get.
What the heck?
(audience laughing)
How the hell were they
feeding in these waters?
They're considered unproductive
because they're warm.
This was my eureka moment.
Not everyone can say that their
careers started with
a pile of (bleep).
(audience laughing)
But I'm pretty pleased
to be able to do that.
(audience laughing)
The thing is, this
moment spiraled
into me pioneering
blue whale research
in the Northern Indian Ocean.
I launched the first
long term study
on this population of pretty
much unknown blue whales.
Crazy but true,
and it has set me
on an incredible adventure.
In the intervening years I
have discovered that in fact,
these waters, because
of the enclosed nature
of the Northern Indian Ocean,
the situation of Sri
Lanka's southern coast
is extremely productive
for that latitude.
I've gone on to name them
the "unorthodox whales,"
because they actually break the
stereotypes we had
for this species.
They don't undertake
long range migrations,
they actually have a
very limited range.
They hang out all
year round in warm
tropical waters of the
Northern Indian Ocean.
They're the smallest
of the blue whales
that you'll find in the oceans.
They're called
pygmy blue whales.
They grow to 80 feet, not 100.
They have a different
acoustic dialect.
They also have
different behaviors.
They lift their tail flukes
up before a deep dive
more often than anywhere
else in the world,
so you'll see this
about 60% of the time,
whereas anywhere else,
less than 20% of the time.
It's a photographer's
dream destination.
Blue whales everywhere
in the world
are called stenophagous,
because they're
very specific, they feed
on one single thing, krill.
These guys feed on
something different.
But the key thing
here is that they have
all these different
behaviors and adaptations,
because they are
living in a very
confined space over
a very limited range.
And during the
course of my work,
I've also met the oldest
blue whale in our population.
I took this photograph in
2011 on a documentary shoot,
and as soon as I
saw the markings,
I thought to myself, I
have seen you before.
Luckily, not a lot of work had
gone on before on these whales.
In fact, there was only
one paper that existed
in the history of our
nation, and that was
done in 1984, and you can see,
and I've named it Whalentine.
(audience laughing)
But the point is, this
animal is at least
27 years old and it's
living in our waters,
but what's really cool
about this sighting
is that you can see,
where I saw the whale
in 2011 was just less
than 10 kilometers away
from where it was
sighted in 1984.
So, we're getting a
sense of sight fidelity,
how important this area
is to these animals.
We know they're feeding,
breeding, and calving
in a very confined space,
so the conservation problems
they face are far
more compounded.
Right now my crusade
is about saving
these whales from
getting killed by ships.
The southern coast of Sri Lanka
is one of the busiest
shipping lanes in the world.
It's the main artery
through the Indian Ocean.
Everything from
Singapore to Dubai
cruises right
through these waters.
Here's some of the data we have.
The red lines are showing
you this dense ship traffic.
The black dots, those
are whale sightings.
Look at the south coast.
There's a distinct overlap.
So sightings like this,
are totally unsurprising.
This is a whale
that came wrapped
on the bow of a container ship
into the main port in Sri
Lanka, in Colombo, in 2012.
12 days later we
had another carcass
floating at sea with a
massive propeller gash.
The thing is, evidence like this
can be a little
bit rare, because
oftentimes the
carcasses will sink,
get pushed off shore,
or they'll deteriorate
so much that when
they come on to shore,
we can't actually identify
the cause of death.
But calculations
show that for every
one we document, at least
ten have gone undocumented.
So it's not an
isolated incident.
Neither are the numbers small.
90% of the vessels that cruise
through our waters are actually
bypassing my country,
they're not coming into port.
So if we can shift
the shipping lanes
15 nautical miles
off shore, we can
reduce the problem
significantly.
And then that 10
percent of vessels
that are actually
coming into port,
well if they slowed
down a little
it would make a difference.
I've done the
science, I've created
all the awareness,
and now I'm pushing
for policy change,
both at the level of
Sri Lankan government, but also
intergovernmentally,
because shipping lanes
are a slightly complex problem.
But my work is not just
about saving whales.
My work is about showing the
talent of the developing world.
I believe that we get
local scientists trained
so they can start looking
after their own waters
using local solutions, that is
what creates sustainability.
And I invite all
of you to join me
on this audacious,
audacious journey,
to achieve this for the sake
of the oceans and humanity.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)